yeah I skipped on a legal place our
current estimate Oscar OTT says that
there is no shortage of pricey SUVs on
the market with a sticker price of
100,000 euros some are even suitable for
off-road driving but until now there
hasn't been a truly luxury SUV out there
something along the lines of a large
touring sedan like a Bentley that's also
suitable off the road the new Bentley
been taken has changed that annoying
Bentley of Antigua it's a very elegant
car you could even call it stately but
that still raises a question as
month--is points out who really needs a
car like this nobody really needs one
but when it comes to luxury cars that's
beside the point the question is who
wants one and who can afford it good
question in Germany the VIN tag is sells
for well over 200 thousand euros what's
the first impression monta says he
doesn't feel like he's sitting and a
two-ton plus SUV the handling is very
smooth and precise and there's no roll
to the left or the right
when you drive quickly into a curve not
bad and the interior also meets with his
approval Martha says he likes that
Bentley hasn't made the move to a fully
digital instrument cluster real chrome
rings on the dash just looked nicer than
chrome rings on a display the Bentley
has a very elegant - with a large
central display it has a harmonious look
that's suited to this class of vehicle
and in other ways to the been taken is
the pinnacle of luxury not just says
it's evident in the details for example
on the instrument panel where the gauges
are protected by a sheet of glass rather
than the ordinary plastic another nice
detail up here is that the overhead
reading light responds to pressure it
doesn't need an extra button they are
given I didn't figure so the bodega is a
winner on the roads but what about off
the asphalt six liters 12 cylinders 447
kilowatts that should be enough to
handle a bit of off road driving and
indeed the been take a foot SUP a
spirited performance the only downside
has visibility Monta says he can't see
much here's the top and now he's headed
down again steve of the art electronic
control systems keep the vent a go on
course
ghandar timer says a v8 diesel is due in
a year and a v6 hybrid in two years that
will be Bentley Motors first vehicle
that can go fully electric with a range
of about 50 kilometers in the city but
the first version off the block is a
power pack 12 cylinder
Malthus says the bent egg is quite handy
offroad
but he's not really sure if he'd want to
drive a car in this price category and
terrain like this instead
he heads for some terrain where there
are no rocks or trees to scratch the
paint job out into the desert for some
dune boarding but do SUVs like the been
taken need to be able to handle sand
Montes says he's never driven a car like
this in the sand before
please roll fake admits that sand
driving might not seem crucial but they
found that in the Middle East how well a
car handles sand is a very important
criterion Jesus fought sexy killing the
Sun giving lists the men take a handle
sand like a pro but the driver needs a
break time to take a look at the
exterior a Bentley trademark is the
prominent chrome front grille and the
speed swept Bentley beyond the sides
the rear is also trademark Bentley
under the hood there's the w12 engine
there's no sign of downsizing here this
is improved time now to see what else
the bent anga can do we're joined by
Derrick Bell a racecar driver who's a
five-time Lamar champion today he'll do
a few rounds with us on the racetrack
well you drove many cars yeah you really
drove many cars really drove very fast
and very very powerful cars yeah is it
comparable to to the limo cars you can't
compare it obviously because of the high
sheer height of the car but the actual
performance of it and the actual
impression you get of the car is of a
sports car obviously it isn't but it's
amazing and I forget then I'm in an SUV
when I'm driving it you can drive the
car around the track as if it's a sports
car which is very rare Bentley's been
taga is a sports car that shines both on
the road and on sand as a deluxe dune
buggy the been take it really shows what
it's made up off-road it masters the
terrain with ease and feels like a
comfortable touring sedan close to the
perfect car for every kind of driving if
it weren't for the price and the fuel
consumption
let's get caught with the history manual
Schaefer says there are many alternative
drive systems nowadays the Toyota Prius
has been a pioneer ever since the first
model came out in 1997 but the 4th
generation has big changes in store the
only thing it has in common with the
previous model is the silent startup in
electric mode the new prius boasts an
entirely redeveloped 1.8 liter gasoline
engine with an output of 72 kilowatts in
combination with a hybrid system that
power is 90 kilowatts top speed is 180
kilometers an hour according to Toyota
fuel consumption is 3 liters over 100
kilometers
the manual says the electric range is
just 2 kilometers but it speeds up to
110 km/h you can take your foot off the
gas the car switches to electric mode
then you Coast and don't use any fuel at
all and the previous model of the Prius
this was possible only up to a top speed
of 70 kilometers per hour
the cars front has been given a sporty
look the previous model looks almost
stodgy by comparison the fourth
generation is also the first Prius to
implement Toyota's new global
architecture or TNG a compared to its
predecessor the new hybrid has improved
handling and stability and the new
platform also lends the design a more
athletic field
the futuristic design is especially
evident in the rear the split rear
window is a prius trademark the manual
says the car's interior matches the
futuristic exterior the radio and the
displays have a high-tech appearance
that suits the car's overall design the
steering wheel is not quite as
attractive but it's acceptable but a
manual says he's not a fan of the white
plastic he'd choose something else
because this will look dirty quite
quickly otherwise the interior has a
clean well-organized feel to it apart
from the instrument cluster in the
center everything is pretty much where
you'd expect it
the center console also has a wireless
charging tray for Qi enabled smartphones
and a head-up display provides the
driver with all necessary information
the seats have been redesigned and the
seating position has been optimized
the manual says this fourth generation
Prius has more cargo space because the
battery pack has been relocated to
underneath the rear passenger seat does
that affect rear legroom in manual says
no there's still plenty of legroom about
a palms width the base price for the
fourth generation Prius is just over
28,000 euros in Germany but that gets
you a nice package of standard features
including a pre collision system
adaptive cruise control lane departure
alert and buy LED headlights with an
automatic high-beam system
a new convertible version of the mini is
set to hit car showrooms its textiles
soft top can open or close automatically
in just 18 seconds even while driving at
speeds of up to 30 km/h in keeping with
tradition rollover protection has been
integrated into the car's body making it
invisible to the eye the convertible is
10 centimeters longer than the previous
model increasing the car's luggage space
by some 25% to mark the 20th anniversary
of its Boxster Series Porsche has
redesigned the mid-engined roadster the
next generation models will be called
the 718 Boxster and 718 Boxster S
they'll be powered by newly developed
turbocharged four-cylinder boxer engines
it's the first time since the late 1960s
that Porsche has introduced sportscar
models with flat-4 engines be 718
Boxster S will have 2.5 litres of cubic
capacity and an output of 257 kilowatts
allowing the Roadster to roar from 0 to
100 kilometers an hour at just 4.2
seconds
crossover our car tester Yan Becker says
chromosomes are all the rage right now
so VW has introduced an all track
version of its caddy model but it's the
off-road look just for show or is it
really an all-terrain vehicle the Caddy
Alltrack is the successor the VW's caddy
cross lifestyle model all track buyers
can choose from the range of for
gasoline or seven diesel engines offered
for the regular caddy a natural gas
variant is available too unfortunately
VW's 4motion permanent all-wheel drive
system is only available as an optional
extra with the two most powerful diesel
engines with an output of 90 or 100
kilowatts respectively we're testing the
smaller all wheel drive version VW says
average fuel consumption is 5.4 liters
per 100 kilometers driven our test
vehicle sells for just over thirty one
and a half thousand euros in Germany
designed to be a lifestyle vehicle the
Caddy Alltrack looks the part with us
three elegant chrome trim strips in the
radiator grille the black plastic trim
on the wheel arches and rocker panels
underscore the off-road look practical
sliding doors on both sides of the
vehicle make for easy entry but what
jaan really likes are the rear seats
they can be folded down or moved out of
the way entirely which is probably the
more practical solutions practice the
visible behind its large tailgate the
Caddy Alltrack boasts over 3,000 litres
of cargo space as well as the passenger
version the Alltrack comes as a panel
van with optional rear wing doors the
Spartan interior is pepped up with
carbon fiber in chrome trim and there
are plenty of storage compartments in
the dash the transmission tunnel and the
door panels as well as a large shelf
under the roof but now it's time to take
the Caddy Alltrack off-road to see what
it's really made of
John says the Caddy Alltrack doesn't
have much trouble handling moderately
rough terrain thanks to its
all-wheel-drive an off-road abs and then
there's the Hill Start Assist which
means he only has to give gas and steer
the Hill Start Assist means the Caddy
Alltrack can make it up extremely steep
inclines from a standing start without
losing traction but a hill descent
control like Skoda offers for its Yeti
outdoor is it available for the all
track not even as an optional extra so
drivers have to make skillfully use of
the clutch and brakes to get the caddy
all track downhill safely
Yan finds the steering quite smooth and
direct but he notes that the suspension
is rock-hard as the vehicles designed to
carry up to 709 kilos of cargo although
the Caddy Alltrack is essentially a pack
mule on wheels its combination of
independent wheel suspension at the
front and rigid rear axle works
surprisingly well here the VW passes our
axle articulation test with flying
colors
John says the candy all track combines
plenty of cargo and storage space with
off-road capacity so it's a good
all-rounder that's also a true sport
utility vehicle
it's one of the dilemmas of winter
driving you're headed up a hill but you
don't have enough traction to handle the
ice and snow that can even happen with
four-wheel drive vehicles like the say
oddly on experience
that's why car tester van ho Dyson
Topher will show us how to put on and
take off snow chains they're essential
for safe handling and many ski regions
like here in the Austrian Alps even if
you think they're not really necessary
they're mandatory on many roads that's
indicated by a round blue sign like this
there are different kinds of snow chains
the best known are cable chains and
clamp chains but not every kind fits on
every car
Vegas naked inode says you should first
check the manufacturers handbook to see
what kind of chains are best and
remember chains should always go on the
drive tires uneven and excellent yet
your manufacturer's handbook will tell
you more if you have all-wheel drive for
example it will say which of the two
drive axles is correct once that's
settled you can go to work a car mat is
a good idea if you're not wearing ski
clothes and saw our gloves if it's cold
the instructions for putting on the
chains are almost as important as the
chains themselves be sure to follow the
instructions step-by-step and properly
mounted snow chains are a safety hazard
make sure the chain isn't twisted and
shows no signs of damage then start
mounting the chains if you're using hook
fasteners make sure you hear this the
click will tell you that the fastener is
engaged
once the chains are securely fastened
they can be tightened up and then you're
good to go
if the users manual doesn't indicate
otherwise it's a good idea to switch off
drivers assistant systems such as ESP or
traction control the cars electronics
can't sense that snow chains are
installed and might even counteract
their effect once you're back on clear
streets you'll need to take special care
I note says snow chains only make sense
in the ice and snow on ordinary asphalt
they're loud increase fuel consumption
wear out quickly damage the road and
affect handling
he's driving just thirty kilometers per
hour and handling is already mushy 50
kilometers per hour is the maximum with
snow chains so it's best to put the
chains on when you need them and take
them up once you don't taking the chains
off is much the same in Reverse one tip
when you're mounting the chains remember
which parts are on the top and bottom of
the tire and put your car in the same
position release the fasteners and give
it all a hard pull the rest is easy
just drive off the chains and gather
them up again
I know recommence washing the chains at
home in warm water and let them dry and
store them in their original packaging
and for optimal safety be sure to read
the snow chains manufacturer's
instructions carefully first the Vega
phacelia was a truly ambitious
undertaking it was envisaged as a
challenger to Porsche and Alfa Romeo in
the late 1950s
it's young French manufacturer if I said
wanted to enter a new segment 1959 saw
the launch of a new little Facel called
the phacelia the two-seater sports car
was unveiled to the public at the Paris
Motor Show
the phacelia went down well among
well-heeled car drivers with a thousand
units ordered before the year was out
being seen behind the wheel of a
festival available as both a convertible
and coupe a the Visalia came with a
specially designed engine a
four-cylinder unit with two overhead
camshafts the 1.6 liter powerplant
delivered about 115 horsepower the
phacelia competed in the mid-range
luxury sports car segment says vintage
car fan beat Loy it was pitted against
the Alfa Giulietta Spyder and Porsche
356 but its price tag put it out of
contention Quinn's fake it ended up
costing almost as much as a Jaguar
e-type on the outside the facility was
clearly related to fassl's larger luxury
models packing a v8 engine but the
designers gave the little speedster
little in the way of the American
styling seen in previous models with or
without a roof it cut a fine figure
the rear had a bold chunky design with
sloped lights
it was flamboyant and glamorous
peristyle oco-2 Cassell had already made
itself a name in the industry as a coach
maker for other manufacturers in the
early 1950s explains our vintage
enthusiasts facilities for car makers
such as simcha and to a lesser extent
Bentley in 1954 when jean-denis nose
took over at the top they decided to
become a luxury French car manufacturer
from civilization Luke's a slogan the
firm's experience paid off the interior
was dominated by lush leather and
carpets though the finish was not what
you'd get from a volume producer
the Facel Vega brand was also known for
its dashboards which looked like they're
made of wood but are actually painted
metal the young car maker planned to
shift up to 2,000 phacelia a year an
ambitious target but the innovative new
engine proved the downfall of both the
model and its maker a large number of
the engines failed costing Facel dearly
in terms of both warranty repairs and
reputation
the company decided to install a new
superior engine but it was too little
too late
the first engine had been commissioned
from pondan assume that are known for
its gearboxes borrowing from Alfa Romeo
it had two overhead camshafts and ample
revs but more aggressive drivers who
wanted to get the most out of the
four-cylinder unit were often left
stranded with a bust
engine and the switch to a mobile engine
was not enough to save the facili
this one was a cross between excessive
ambition and poor business partnership
in next to no time the car had a
disastrous reputation thanks to the
infamous ancient and that meant the end
for facade sultanu process fossils can a
kikah pro cannot Facel replaced 300
engines in the interest of customer
relations relations it would soon no
longer have in 1964 the luxury French
carmaker shut down forever
today the phacelia is a great option for
vintage enthusiasts after an exclusive
classic car for a less than exclusive
price a convertible in good condition
will cost you around thirty five
thousand euros the engines and the later
models as we now know are more reliable
phacelia is ideal if you want a special
car that many people will recognize as
if I sell but not the exact model the
final version the F to be at a decent
engine so there were no more overheating
problems dakotans an elephant or a prawn
the phacelia a diva of a car with a
fascinating allure but no shortage of
idiosyncrasies